so
[Music]
um
so
okay
well good morning
as we begin the new year
i want to speak to you about the ongoing
battle with covet 19
and the challenges posed by the omicron
variant
throughout this pandemic
i made a promise to you to speak plainly
about the virus
and how ontario is responding
to share with you what i know
what our experts have told us
and to never shy away from being upfront
with the people of ontario
as you know
like in other provinces in countries
around the world
omicron case accounts
are rising exponentially across the
province
we face a tsunami
of new cases in the days and weeks ahead
and as we do
virtually everyone in this province
will know someone who has been exposed
to this virus
now
we're bracing for impact
based on a real world experience here in
ontario the evidence tells us
that about one percent of people who get
omicron will end up in the hospital
that may not seem a lot and under past
waves it might have been something we
could withstand
but omicron isn't like the other
variants
it's much much more transmissible
so the math
isn't on our side
based on the current trends our public
health experts tell us we could see
hundreds of thousands of cases
every single day
one percent of hundreds of thousands is
too many new patients for our hospitals
to handle
over the past few days we've started to
see
an alarming number of new hospital
emissions
now with triple digit emissions into
hospitals
every single day
this is a problem that will only get
worse as we confront the looming wave of
omicron
the reality is
the people are coming into hospital and
leaving soon after sometimes only
staying
for a couple days
this is very different problem
than we faced in the past
when coved hospitals stay
were weeks along in intensive care units
but even so
with omicron surging across ontario at a
current rate
ontario health modeling tells us we
could be thousands of beds short in the
coming weeks
we can't let that happen
this data is clear call
to further action
we must do everything in our powers to
protect our hospitals and to assure our
front line workers aren't overwhelmed
we've been adding new beds across the
province for many months and will
continue to do so
the investments we've made in our
hospitals are larger than any previous
government in the history of ontario
but
with a variant as infectious as omicron
with spreads like nothing we've seen
before
added capacity alone isn't enough
we need to implement measures that
further reduce contacts and mobility
effective wednesday january 5th at 1201
a.m
ontario will return to a modified step
two of the road not to reopen
the plan will be released
before we confronted omicron laid out
two clear reasons why
we would implement province-wide
measures
first
the introduction of a new variant
second if our health care system was
threatened
today we face both of these
our plan demands that we implement
additional public health measures
minister elliott will share details with
you shortly on what exactly this entails
but it will mean the closure of more
indoor spaces where we know the risk of
transmission is higher
especially with omicron
but let me be clear
these will be targeted and they will be
time limited the immediate goal of these
measures
will be to blunt the latest waves so we
can ease the pressure on our hospitals
and allow more time to deliver
these all-important booster shots which
continue at a tremendous pace
because vaccines remain
the key to our long-term success against
this virus
and the call to arms we issued last
month
has been answered loud and clear
we have delivered over 24 million shots
to ontarians
including 3.7 million booster shots
and over 1300 regulated healthcare
professionals
both active and retired have stepped up
to support the vaccine effort
this includes firefighters first
responses first responders and health
professionals
this display of selflessness
and ontario spirit has exceeded our
expectations
and we are so grateful to each and every
one of them
but we need to give our booster effort
time
it needs to succeed
and that means doing whatever possible
to slow the spread of omicron
and i say slow the spread
because it can't be stopped
look to other countries other provinces
it's too contagious to stop completely
so we need to slow it down in order to
deliver these shots and ensure our
hospital stays strong
that is what these measures will do so
there is no choice but to act quickly
and get them in place for a limited
period of time
but just because the way forward was
clear
that doesn't mean these decisions are
without cost
and i understand these costs are
significant
and the hardship of these decisions are
not shared equally
that's why we're introducing expanded
supports for small businesses and it's
why i've asked minister bethanpalvi to
continue working on fast tracking more
supports for businesses that have
already shouldered so much of this
pandemic
and to all the parents
i'm going to tell you that these
measures will have an effect on our
schools as well
we need to prioritize the continued
health and safety of our kids
and our school staff
as a result we'll be delaying the return
to in-class learning for the next two
weeks and continue with virtual learning
for the duration of the time away
i know this isn't the news anyone wants
to hear
but with the new variant the ground is
shifting every single day
the level of absenteeism we're seeing in
other sectors tells us with absolute
certainty that operating schools
ensuring teachers are on the job and not
homesick will be a challenge
we cannot overcome in the short term
these two weeks will provide much needed
time for more vaccines more boosters
it's more time for additional public
health measures to blunt the rapid rise
in cases
i know online learning isn't ideal
but above all else i want to provide
students and parents with certainty
not the turmoil of school closures
because not enough staff are available
to teach our kids
now these decisions
will disappoint people
they will confuse some people
and they will anger some people i
understand all those reactions
as premier these are the hardest
decisions i make
but we follow the data and the fact is
this
omicron spreads like wildfire
it only takes the smallest opportunity
to infect
and if we do not act if we don't do
everything possible to get this variant
under control
the results could be catastrophic
it is a risk i cannot take
not after what we've been through and
what we've been able to accomplish
together
we are now entering the third calendar
year of this pandemic
it is being the greatest challenge of
our generation
we want this to be the year when we
finally win the war against coved and
begin the road to recovery
to do that we must show more
determination more resolve than ever
before
it's never been easy
and it won't start now
but we can and we will get through this
i want to thank you and god bless the
people of ontario now i'll pass it over
to minister elia
thank you premier
as supremer mentioned in ontario we have
recently seen a rapid increase in
covid19 hospitalizations
the latest evidence has demonstrated
that while the omicron variant is less
severe its high transmissibility has
resulted in a larger number of
short-term hospital admissions
recently we reported our highest number
of cases ever and this is expected to
increase further in the coming days
this rapid rise of omicron cases
combined with staph absenteeism due to
omicron infection and exposure
could result in the province's hospital
capacity becoming overwhelmed if further
action isn't taken to curb transmission
and as dr moore has continued to say as
the evidence on omicron continues to
evolve our pandemic response must evolve
with it
that's why effective wednesday january
5th the province will return to a
modified version of step two of the
roadmap to reopen
these time limited measures will help
blunt transmission and preserve our
hospital bed capacity
measures include reducing social
gathering limits to five people indoors
and ten people outdoors
requiring businesses and organizations
to ensure employees work remotely unless
the nature of their work requires them
to be on site
closing indoor dining at restaurants
bars and other food or drink
establishments while permitting outdoor
dining with restrictions takeout
drive-through and delivery
closing select indoor settings including
theaters cinemas and museums but
permitting outdoor establishments to
open with restrictions
closing indoor sport and recreational
facilities including gyms and permitting
outdoor sport facilities to operate with
certain requirements
retail settings including shopping malls
will operate at 50 capacity along with
personal care services
and indoor weddings funerals and
religious services will be limited to 50
percent capacity with outdoor services
limited to the number of people that can
maintain two meters of physical distance
in addition on january 5th the province
will reinstate directive 2 for hospitals
and regulated health professionals
instructing hospitals to pause all
non-emergent and non-urgent surgeries
and procedures
in order to preserve critical care and
human resource capacity in the health
care system
these measures will be in place for at
least 21 days until january 26 2022
subject to trends and key indicators and
of course in consultation with ontario's
chief medical officer of health
i want everyone to know this was not an
easy decision
this is not the situation any of us
wanted to be in
i know everyone is tired especially
after what was a tough holiday season
but based on the data emerging evidence
on omicron and what our hospital
partners are experiencing on the ground
these additional time limited measures
are needed to preserve our hospital
capacity as we accelerate our booster
dose rollout
we are vaccinating hundreds of thousands
of people every day and i strongly urge
everyone to please get your first
second or booster dose as soon as you
can
by implementing these time limited
measures we will get through this
critical period in january and continue
our work to end this pandemic once and
for all
thank you
okay we'll take questions from the floor
before we move to the phones just a
reminder it's one question and one
follow-up
hello premier and the rest um
you've given us some
basic sort of back of the napkin math
about what 50 000 uh cases in a day
would do to the hospital system um but
the government's no longer
tracking cases with the same rigor that
it was before and people have been told
to simply assume that they have coveted
um if they show symptoms so what are the
metrics being used and when must they be
met by for the for all these measures
things like non-urgent surgeries to
resume schools to reopen gyms to reopen
to happen because there's there's no
timeline that you've given here yeah i
think this would be best answered by dr
moore
thank you premier the most important
metric that we're monitoring is the
hospitalization rate
we know omicron's going to have a
significant burden on admissions to
hospitals so that we can provide the
right care to the right people at the
right time
those individuals chiefly primarily
require oxygen we've been following the
data very closely and
the vast majority won't require icu or
mechanical ventilation which is good
news for us but we'll still maintain
obviously that capacity in that service
if and when needed so ontarians and all
key decision makers should be monitoring
the hospitalization rates uh that will
ascend fairly rapidly over the coming
weeks we anticipate that it will reach
its maximum by the end of january and
then start to descend so we anticipate a
very short quick and rapid
approach to this
epidemic and impact on the health care
system that is why these measures are
timely they're proportionate to the risk
they should diminish the burden on the
health care system they should buy us
time to be able to increase their doses
to prevent hospitalization they'll also
buy us time for the arrival of
antivirals which could decrease the
burden on hospitalization to be able to
decrease
that burden by providing outpatient oral
therapies for individuals
these are sacrifices that we'll all have
to make
but if we're looking particularly at the
metric which was your key question it's
all about monitoring the impact on the
health care system
because this is so transmissible passing
so rapidly through our communities that
is the burden that we're trying to
prevent
so with that being said and you saying
that i believe the um
this increase in cases will
reach its peak by the end of january but
schools are only closed for the next two
weeks so should we instead assume that
schools will actually be closed until
the end of january at which point we'll
have a better idea of
of um what sort of impact this has had
because you know people want certainty
we're two years into this premier you
just said that you know people want
certainty
what sort of certainty can we give about
a timeline here um or or really is the
best answer that there is no certainty
at this point for certainty it you know
we've projected these um this impact on
the health care system through modeling
through actively monitoring the current
cases that we have
and their acceleration
on hospitalization so
that prediction
may be diminished by these public health
measures uh by uh increasing a provision
of uh immunization in the community
certainly uh the time that we have now
from the fifth to the seventeenth for
schools gives us extra time to be able
to provide access for students for
workers in that environment to best
protect them to have a safe opening and
we're constantly reviewing best
practices in the school setting to keep
them as safe as we can but all of this
has been data driven
and um
absolutely this government has shown
that it will follow the data and monitor
the risk uh the intervention of public
health measures is deemed to be
short-term uh to blunt um the impact on
the health care system and is different
than what we put in place at other times
in this pandemic where we've tried to
totally decrease the case count and get
us through the whole
three or four months of the threat of
the various variants that have
circulated in ontario that is not the
purpose of these public health measures
we're not going to be able to stop it
we'll have to blunt it as best we can
through the sacrifices of ontarians
and uh at the same time maintaining all
essential services
okay and we're ready to move to the
phones
chris rochelle toronto star
hi chris
oh hi thanks for taking my questions
just a few days ago your government and
dr moore announced that schools would
open on january 5th that it was safe to
do so and the children had already
sacrificed enough in this pandemic so
what exactly has changed since then to
make you change your mind
well there's three major factors and
it's case counts right off the
the hop and hospitalization
uh i'll just put that into perspective
for people
the report i was told
that we could see hundreds of thousands
of cases let's be conservative let's say
a hundred thousand cases or two hundred
thousand that's a day that's a thousand
people
two thousand people showing up to
hospitals
uh that that uh that's not sustainable
so we have to look at the the case
counts for hospitalizations and then we
have to protect their hospitals but
another big factor and i spent all
weekend uh speaking obviously to
the health professionals dr
dr moore and matt anderson that's joined
us today ceo of of ontario health i've
spoken to the
labor leaders i've spoken to numerous
ceos of large corporations uh one one
ceo told me a large courier company
told me that they they saw 300 people in
a single day not show up to work
we want to make sure
that we protect the the frontline
healthcare workers we want to make sure
we we protect
the students and the teachers along
along with the general public
you know this took me about 30 seconds
to make a decision it was a decisive
decision and we're going to make sure
that
we go through this and be as cautious as
possible and use every tool in our
toolbox
to sustain not only our health care but
our economy as well
follow-up thank you yes and i'm just
wondering how can parents plan ahead and
trust you when you say that schools will
reopen because in the past you've kept
just kept extending virtual schooling
more so than any other province
well again the number one priority is is
to make sure
that the kids have an opportunity
to learn online that's absolutely
critical but we have to protect
the the overall system when i when i
talk about the system i'm talking again
the hospitalization
the schools uh the economy the
businesses that's who we have to protect
and we've never seen anything like this
and let's keep in mind this isn't uh
just ontario based
everyone watches the news you see what's
happening across the world you see
what's happening across our country and
in our u.s neighbors
we're going to make sure that we throw
everything we have we will not spare a
penny to make sure we can get through
this surge of omicron cases
next question
adrian gabriel cdtv
hi premier when it comes to the school
closures let's say they are closed just
for the next two weeks
is there anything that your government
can tell parents that they're going to
actively do in the next two weeks
to fortify our schools to give them a
fighting chance of reopening we're
looking at a rapid testing program
anything at all that you guys are doing
above and beyond what has already been
done when it comes to safety in schools
yeah well first of all i want to give a
shout out to minister leche i
always say he's the best minister of
education in the country he has done
everything
in his power to make sure that schools
can move forward throughout this this
whole pandemic he's made sure that he we
have n95 mass for educators which is
unheard of by the way
there's no jurisdiction in in canada
that has n95 uh masks we're going to
make sure that the cleaning uh enhances
the the cleaning we're making sure that
we have the rapid test he he sent out 11
million tests
right across this province
he's doing an incredible job we're going
to continue focusing on on making sure
that not not just schools but everywhere
right across the the province can move
forward uh this may be a bump
in the road and a pretty big bump as i
as i said we're going to get hit like a
tsunami i also said brace for impact
because
some people don't understand the volume
that's going to hit us
and again if we have a thousand or two
thousand people showing up to hospitals
across this province
it's going to be very very challenging
and to speak about the hospitals and the
challenges
they they're facing i would like to
bring up matt anderson matt has been an
absolute champion right from the
beginning of this pandemic
no matter if it came to testing or
keeping our hospitals safe and up and
going and i just want to tell you you
may not see him on tv a lot but
he's just
a real
machine behind the scenes that are
driving
the hospitals and moving them forward so
matt if you could come up for a minute
thank you premier thank you for the
opportunity to come and speak today and
thank you everyone
and good morning
just a few things i think that i would
highlight from what's been discussed
already
our big challenge as you've already
heard
is the
really big increase in cases and this is
different we've we've talked about this
you heard dr moore mention it before
this is a different wave for us these
are cases that are coming into our wards
meaning our our main areas within the
hospital we're seeing those cases climb
very dramatically we're seeing this in
other parts of the world as well
we have to be ready to try to bring that
curve down
and every day matters for us what you're
hearing today
are
plans and things that are hopefully
going to blunt that curve to use the
words of dr moore
extraordinarily important that we try to
blunt that curve to push off when does
this peak happen inside our hospitals if
we can push this off far enough allowing
vaccine to work allowing us to get
antivirals into our environment
we can get to a place where we do not
have this overwhelming our health care
system and i just make it the additional
comment as well
we talk about the hospital system
but it is the whole health care system
this is about home care this is about
long-term care it's about primary care
all of the system has to be on its feet
working together to make sure that we
are supporting our citizens in the
places where they need care the most
when we think about that
certainly our directive two
which is to limit uh procedures and
surgeries within our hospitals to keep
them at urgent and emergent only that is
a hospital initiative but the public
health measures that we're talking about
here go beyond that you've also heard a
lot about health human resources we're
very challenged in health human
resources in all sectors our public
health measures are intended to help in
all sectors as we make sure that our
home care our long-term care our primary
care all stay online and are able to
assist in this
effort to make sure that we are here to
support
all of you as we go through
this challenging time together so it's
really bringing all of those pieces
together anything that we can do
together
to keep pushing back that wave
buys us more time
helps our hospitals but helps all of our
health care system uh in our response to
covet thank you follow up
thanks for that you know without any
doubt you know i don't think anyone's
questioning just how hard people are
working however my question was about
what's being done over at least the next
two weeks
to reinforce the safety measures in our
schools
that question wasn't answered so i'll
ask this question instead
you've we've previously heard you know
parents across the problems have
previously heard that schools should be
the last to close and the first to
reopen
in today's announcement retail is still
allowed to remain open at 50 capacity
is anyone able to promise families
across this province that schools will
be reopened before any other business
sector
is reopened
well what i can tell you
when it comes to the schools and i did
mention a lot of things already
but
we have to make sure that right across
the province
when it comes to absenteeism and this
doesn't just affect the schools uh the
the teachers and and other other areas
uh no matter if it's healthcare or or
businesses the economy
we have to make sure we have people in
the classroom
make sure we have teachers in the
classroom we have to make sure we have
people in in the factories and in
offices to make sure we keep the economy
going we have to make sure we protect
our health care workers uh to make sure
that they're they'll be able to go into
the hospitals and and support uh people
coming in so it's not just about uh
making sure that the the schools are
safe i think it goes hand in hand right
across the board uh the when there's
community spread at this uh at this rate
that we've seen that vertical spike on
on the cases like we've never seen
before again when you have a hundred two
hundred three hundred thousand uh people
getting sick
and one two three thousand people are
showing up to to the hospitals
that's that's my number one concern to
make sure that we
maintain a strong health care system and
with the people behind me i have 100
percent confidence that's going to
happen
next question
holly mckenzie suiter canadian press
hi i want to ask about the
directive on hospitals and the surgeries
um i mean this is something that
yourself and
health system officials have said
wouldn't happen again during the
pandemic and now it is
um
and it's not really clear to me from
this announcement why
now is the right time to be reposing
these non-urgent surgeries and i'm
wondering if you could expand a little
bit on
what what are the factors behind that
decision is it a staffing issue or
are you know are we unable to care for
all the people in icu right now i'm just
wondering if you could elaborate on what
has made this the moment to actually
positive surgeries that as you know the
backlog's gotten higher and people you
know they could be life-changing for a
lot of people well i'll pass this over
to minister elliot and then over to dr
dr moore thank you
well you're right many people have been
waiting to have surgeries and procedures
done for a long period of time and we
have been working on that in the last
few months
but with the omicron variant spiking in
the way that it is and with the numbers
of hospitalizations increasing rapidly
we will
unfortunately need the the bed spaces as
well as the staff in order to be able to
treat people with omicron and whatever
else comes in to the hospital that they
needed to be treated for
so we are facing
absenteeism of many health care workers
because they also have omicron and we
are trying to build up those reserves we
have introduced about 300 new people in
the last few months to work in our
hospitals but we need both the spaces as
well as the people in order to to care
for people with omicron but perhaps dr
moore could add more to that
specifically
yeah thank you minister at any given
time in in the coming weeks we can
expect across all sectors to 20 to 30
absenteeism as a result uh of omicron
spreading so rapidly across ontario so
our health system has to start building
continuity of operations plans they have
to anticipate that we won't have as many
staff as necessary
and also we have to also prepare
increased bed capacity so putting in
directive number two
gives us a and we've consulted uh
clearly with matt anderson's who's here
twelve hundred to fifteen hundred
additional beds uh that can provide care
to patients with omicron in the health
system we anticipate through the
modeling that those twelve hundred to
fifteen hundred beds will be essential
to be able to provide oxygen and care
and as the minister has already said
we're
trying to get as many health care
workers back in a shorter time period
but tested with our ats to ensure that
there's no risk of transmission in the
workplace
so all of those plans to ensure
ontarians get the right care at the
right time at the right place are in
play and we're absolutely in doing this
in consultation with all health system
partners
as we anticipate the rapid increase
heading into the second third and fourth
weeks of january
follow-up and this will be the last
question
yeah do you guys have any numbers on how
many procedures are actually going to be
affected by this you know in the day
window and
any idea of how long the wait list is
right now as well that's about anderson
thank you for the question um and uh
first just to say uh it's a very
poignant question um as you've heard uh
throughout the discussion today uh these
decisions um are not taken lightly uh
and there is consequence to them and
we're very aware of that uh in in the
case of specifically to your question um
generally what we would look at through
a typical week would be somewhere
between eight to ten thousand uh
surgeries or other procedures that will
be impacted by this so that would be
what would add uh to our wait list
i don't have a specific wait list date
for you if you uh follow up we can get
you because we track it by procedure um
so we would have to give you that
information by procedure but overall
those are the numbers that we're facing
uh and just to say again we recognize
that although we are facing uh and doing
our emergent surgeries
and our urgent procedures
there is a cost here we're absolutely
sensitive to that and as you've heard
everyone speaking today we want to get
out of this as fast as possible get our
hospitals back up safely
and a key part of that is addressing the
hhr challenges that we have throughout
the system and giving more supports to
those fantastic people who are out there
doing what they need to do every day
it comes with a it was a tough decision
a big cost but something that is
necessary given what we're seeing in the
numbers thank you
was that the last question
well folks i just i just want to speak
to the people across the province i know
this is very very challenging for each
and every one of us across
every single sector uh what i can do is
tell you that
i can assure you we will get through
this
we'll come out of this uh this battle
that we're facing with omicron will come
out stronger than ever before
and we'll get back to life as as normal
as quickly as possible i want to thank
each and every one of you i want to
thank the the frontline healthcare
workers and everyone else
involved
across the province the people
that are putting the shots into arms and
there's just
tens of thousands of people helping out
it's truly team ontario it's the ontario
spirit
and uh we'll together get through this
so thank you and and god bless each and
every one of you thank you
thanks everyone
you